welcome to the future of life institute
podcast i'm lucas perry today's episode
is with daniella and daario amide and in
it we explore anthropic for those not
familiar anthropic is a new ai safety
and research company that's working to
build reliable interpretable and
steerable ai systems their view is that
large general ai systems of today can
have significant benefits but can also
be unpredictable unreliable and opaque
their goal is to make progress on these
issues through research and down the
road create value commercially and for
public benefit daniella and dario join
us to discuss the mission of anthropic
their perspective on ai safety their
research strategy as well as what it's
like to work there and the positions
they're currently hiring for
daniela amide is a co-founder and is the
president of anthropic she was
previously at stripe and open ai and has
also served as a congressional staffer
daario amide is ceo and is also a
co-founder of anthropic he was
previously at openai google and baidu
dario also holds a phd in biophysics
from princeton university before we jump
into the interview we have a few
announcements to make if you've tuned
into any of the previous two episodes
then you can skip ahead just a bit the
first announcement is that i'll be
moving on from my role as host of the
fli podcast and this means two things
the first is that fy is hiring for a new
host for the podcast as host you would
be responsible for the guest selection
interviews production and publication of
the fli podcast if you're interested in
applying for this position you can head
over to the careers tab at
futureoflife.org for more information we
also have another four job openings
currently for a human resources manager
an editorial manager an eu policy
analyst and an operations specialist you
can learn more about those at the
careers tab as well the second item is
that even though i'll no longer be host
of the fli podcast i won't be
disappearing from the podcasting space
i'm starting a brand new podcast that'll
be focused on exploring questions around
philosophy wisdom
science and technology where you'll see
many of the same themes you can find
here like existential risk and ai
alignment i'll have more details about
my new podcast soon if you'd like to
stay up to date you can follow me on
twitter at lucasfm perry link in the
description
and with that i'm happy to present this
interview with daniella and dario amade
on anthropic
[Music]
it's really wonderful to have you guys
here on the podcast i'm super excited to
be learning all about
anthropic um so we can start off here
with a pretty simple question and so you
know what was the intention behind
forming anthropic
yeah cool well first of all lucas thanks
so much for for having us on the show
we've been really looking forward to it
we're super pumped to be here
so i guess maybe i'll i'll kind of start
with this one so just to kind of yeah
why did we start anthropic to kind of
give a little history here and sort of
set the stage we were founded about a
year ago at the beginning of 2021
and it was originally a team of seven
people who kind of moved over together
from from open ai and uh for
listeners or viewers who kind of don't
very viscerally remember this time
period it was like the middle of the
pandemic so most people were not
eligible to be you know vaccinated yet
and so when
you know all of us wanted to kind of get
together and talk about anything we had
to like get together in someone's
backyard or outdoors and be six feet
apart and wear masks and so it was
generally just like a really uh
interesting time to be to be kind of
starting a company
but why you know why did we found
anthropic what was what was the thinking
there i think you know sort of the best
way i would i would describe it is
because we all of us kind of wanted the
opportunity
to make a focused research bet with a
small set of
people who were highly er aligned kind
of around a
very coherent vision of ai research and
ai safety so
the majority of our employees had kind
of worked together in in like one format
or another in the past so you know i
think our team is kind of known for
work like you know gpt 3
uh deep dream chrysola worked on at
google brain for scaling laws but we'd
also done a lot of different uh safety
research together in in in different
organizations that as well so uh
multimodal neurons uh when we're at open
ai concrete problems in ai safety and
sort of a lot of others but this group
had kind of worked together in uh in
different companies at google brain at
open ai and academia
in startups previously and we really
just wanted the opportunity to kind of
get that group together to do this
focused kind of research bet of building
you know steerable interpretable and
reliable ai systems uh with humans at
the center of them yeah just to just to
add a little bit to that i mean i think
you know we're we were we're i think
we're all a bunch of you know like
fairly kind of empirically minded
exploration driven driven people but you
who also think and care a lot about
about ai safety i think that
characterizes you know all all seven of
us if you if you add together you know
having you know either working at open
ai
working together at google brain in the
past uh many of us work together in the
physicist in the physics community and
we're you know current current or former
physicist if you add if you add all that
together i mean it's a set of people who
have kind of known each other for a long
time and you know have been aware of
thinking in arguments about ai safety
and have worked on them over the years
kind of always with an empirical bent
ranging from you know interpretability
on like language models and vision
models to you know working on the
original rl from human preferences
concrete problems and ai safety um and
also characterizing scaling and how
scaling works and how that's um uh kind
of uh yeah how we think of that is
somewhat somewhat central to the way ai
is going to progress and shapes the
landscape for how to how to solve uh how
to solve safety um and so yeah i mean a
year ago we were all working at open ai
and sort of you know trying to make this
focused bet on
you know basically scaling plus safety
or you know or safety safety with a with
a lens towards scaling being a big part
of the path to agi um and yeah i mean we
felt we were making this focus that kind
of within a within a larger organization
and it just eventually came to the
conclusion that it would be great to
have an organization that like top to
bottom was just was just focused on this
bat and could make make kind of all
strategic decisions with this with this
with this bet in mind um and so that was
that was kind of thinking the thinking
and the genesis
yeah i really like the uh
i guess that idea of like a focused bet
uh i hadn't heard that before i like
that um do you all have a uh similar
like philosophy in terms of like your
background since you're all converging
on this work of like safely scaling to
to agi
i think in a broad sense we all have
this view
you know safety is important today and
for the future
we all have this view of kind of i don't
know i would say like pragmatic
practicality like let's you know an
empiricism like let's see
how we can let's see what we can do
today to try and get a foothold on
things the things that might happen in
the future so we're you know like you
know yeah as i said many of us have
background in physics or other natural
scientists i'm a former you know i was
physics undergrad neuroscience uh
neuroscience grad school so yeah we very
much have this kind of empirical mindset
um you know empirical science mindset
more than you know maybe maybe a more
philosophy or theoretical approach um
you know within that obviously
all of us you know if you include the
seven initial folks as well as the
employees who join have our own skills
and our own perspective on things um you
know and have have different different
things within that that that we're
excited about so you know we're not
we're not all clones of the same the
same person right some of us are excited
about interpretability some of us are
excited about um you know like you know
reward learning and preference modeling
um some of us are excited about about
the policy aspects um uh and you know we
each have our own kind of guesses about
the sub path within this broad path that
makes sense but i think we all agree on
this this broad view scaling is
important safety is important getting a
foothold on problems today is important
as a as a window on the future
okay and so this this shared vision that
you all have is around this focused uh
research bet could you tell me a little
bit more about what that that bet is
yeah maybe i'll i'll kind of start here
and then and you know dario feel free to
jump in and add more but i think the
kind of the boilerplate like vision or
mission that you would see if you looked
on our website is that we're building
steerable uh interpretable and reliable
ai systems but i think kind of what that
looks like in in practice is that we are
training large-scale generative models
and we're doing safety research on those
models and you know the kind of reason
that we're doing that is we want to make
the models you know safer and kind of
more aligned with with human values i
think the the alignment paper which you
might have seen that kind of came out
recently there's a term there that we've
been you know using a lot which is we're
aiming to make systems that are helpful
honest and and harmless um
i think also when i
sort of think about the way our teams
are structured like we we kind of have
capabilities as this sort of like
central pillar of research and there's
this like helix of safety research that
kind of wraps around every project that
we that we work on so to give an example
if if we're doing language model
training that's kind of this like
central pillar and then we have
interpretability research which is
trying to see inside models and kind of
understand uh you know what's happening
with the language models under the hood
we're doing alignment research on uh
with with you know input from from human
feedback to kind of try and improve the
outputs of the models we're doing
societal impacts research uh that's kind
of looking at you know what impact on
society in sort of a short and
medium-term way do these language models
have we're doing scaling laws research
to sort of try and predict empirically
you know
what what properties are are we going to
see emerge in these language models at
various sizes um but i think you know
all together that kind of ends up
looking like a team of people that are
working together on on uh like a
combination of of capability and and
skilling work with safety research yeah
i mean one way one way you might put it
is like
you know like there are a lot of things
that an org does that are kind of like
neutral as to as to kind of kind of the
direction that you would take like you
know you have to build a you have to
build a cluster and you have to have
like an hr operation and you have to
have an office and so you can even think
of you know you can even think of kind
of the large models as like
being a bit like the cluster right that
you build these large models and they're
they're kind of blank when you start off
with them and like probably unaligned um
uh but you know it's it's what you do on
top of these models that matters that
like takes you in a safe or not safe
direction in a good or a bad direction
um and so in in a way although they're
although they're ml and although we'll
continue to scale them up you can you
can kind of think of them as a bit as as
as almost part of as almost part of
infrastructure i mean it takes research
and it takes algorithms to get them
right but you can think of them as this
this core part of the infrastructure and
then the interesting question is you
know
all the safety questions what's going on
inside these models how do they operate
how can we make them operate differently
how can we change their objective
functions to be something that we want
rather than something that we don't want
how can we look at their applications
and make those applications more likely
to be positive and less likely to be
negative more likely to go in directions
that people intend and less likely to go
off in directions that people that
people uh that people don't intend um so
we we we almost see the kind of presence
of these large models as like the you
know like the i don't know what the
analogy is like the flower or the paste
like kind of the the background the
background ingredient on which the
things we really care about get get uh
get get get built and sort of the the
like prerequisite for building those
things
so does ai existential safety fit into
these considerations around your safety
and alignment work i think this is you
know this is something we think about
and like part of the part of the
motivation for you know for what for
what we do probably most
listeners of this podcast know what it
is but you know i think i think the most
common form of the concern is hey look
we're making these ei systems they're
getting more and more powerful at some
point they'll be
generally intelligent or more generally
capable than human beings are um and
then you know they may have a large
amount of agency and if if we haven't
built them in such a way that that that
agency is in line with what with what we
want to do um then we could imagine them
doing something really really scary that
we can't that we can't stop um so i
think that you know yeah and you know
that you know to take it even further
this could be you know some kind of some
kind of threat threat to humanity so you
know i mean that's that's an argument
with many steps but it's you know it's
one that you know in a very broad sense
in the long term like you know seems
seems at least potentially at least
potentially legitimate to us i mean this
is you know like like the the argument
seems at least like something that we
should that we should care about um but
i think i think the big question and and
maybe how we
how how we differ although it might be
suddenly from from other other orgs that
that think about these problems um
is you know how do we how do we actually
approach that kind of problem today um
like you know what can we do so you know
i think there are there are various
efforts to think about the ways in which
this might happen to kind of come up
with theories or frameworks um you know
as as as i mentioned with the background
that we have we're more
empirically focused people we're more
inclined to say
we don't we don't really know like that
broad argument sounds kind of plausible
to us and you know the stakes would be
high so you should you know you should
you should think about it but you know
like it's it's hard to work on that
today i'm not even sure how much how
much value there is in talking about
that a lot today um like
you know and so we've taken a very
different tack which is look like
you know
they're actually and i think this has
started to be true in the last couple
years and like maybe wasn't even true
five five years ago that there are
models today
that
have at least some not all of the
properties of models that we'd be
worried about in the future um uh and
are causing very concrete problems today
that affect people today um so can we
take a strategy where
we develop methods that both help with
the problems of today but do so in a way
that could generalize or at least teach
us about the problems of the future um
so our our eye is definitely on you know
these these things these things in the
future um but but i think that if if not
if not kind of grounded in
empirics and the problems of today it
can kind of drift off in a direction
that isn't that isn't very productive
and so that's that's our general
philosophy i mean i think the particular
properties the models are look today we
have models that are really open-ended
in some narrow ways or more capable than
humans i think you know large language
models you know probably know more about
cricket than me because i i don't know
the first thing about cricket um uh and
you know yeah and are also kind of
unpredictable by their by their
statistical nature um and i think those
are at least some of the properties that
we're worried about with uh with uh with
with future uh with future systems um so
you know that we can use today's models
as kind of a laboratory to to scope out
these problems a little better my my
guess is that we don't understand them
very well at all and that this is a way
to learn
could you give some examples of some of
these models that exist today that you
think are you know exhibit these
properties yeah um so you know i think
the most famous one would be generative
language models so you know there's
there's a lot of them there's um you
know there's most famously you know gpt3
from from from uh from open ai which we
which we helped uh build um there's
gopher from deepmind there's like lambda
from from from maine google um i'm
probably leaving out some i think there
have been models you know this size in
like china north korea israel like you
know seems like seems like everyone has
one it seems like everyone has one
nowadays um
uh i don't think it's limited to
language there have also been models
that are focused on code we've seen that
from deepmind openai and some other
players and there are there have also
been
models with modified forms in the same
spirit that that that model images that
generate uh images or that convert
images to text or that convert text to
images um there might be models in the
future that you know that generate
videos or convert videos to videos to
text there's many modifications of it
but i think the general idea is big
models models with a lot of capacity and
a lot of parameters trained on a lot of
data that try try to model some modality
whether that's text code images video
transitions between the two
uh you know or or or or such and yeah i
mean i think you know these models are
very open-ended you can say anything to
them and they'll say anything back they
they might not do a good job of it they
might say something horrible or biased
or bad but but you know but in theory
they're very in theory they're very
they're very general um
uh and so yeah they they you know you're
never quite sure what they're gonna say
you're never quite sure
um
you know you can you can talk to them
about anything any topic and they'll say
something back that's often topical even
though even if sometimes it doesn't make
sense or you know it might be bad from a
societal perspective so yeah it's it's
kind of this this yeah this this
challenge of general open-ended models
um where yeah you have this general
thing that's you know fairly fairly
unaligned and difficult to control and
you'd like to you'd like to understand
it better so that you can predict it
better and you'd like to be able to
to modify them in some way so that they
behave in a more in a more predictable
way and you can decrease the probability
or even maybe even someday rule out the
likelihood of them them doing something
bad
yeah i think i think dario covered
covered the majority of it i think
there's probably uh there's maybe like a
sort of potentially like a hidden
question in in what you're asking
although although maybe you'll ask this
later but you know why like why are we
working on these kind of larger scale
models might might be kind of a an
implicit question in there um and i
think to kind of piggyback on some of
the stuff that that dario said you know
i think part of of what we're seeing and
the sort of potential you know shorter
term impacts of of some of the ai safety
research that we do is that you know
different
different sized models exhibit you know
different safety issues right and so um
i think with you know using again
language models just kind of
building on what on what daria was kind
of talking about
i think something we feel you know
interested in or kind of interested to
explore from this kind of empirical
safety question is just how they will uh
you know as their capabilities develop
how their safety problems develop as
well right there's kind of this this
commonly cited example in in safety
safety world around language models
which is you know
smaller language models kind of show
um
you know they might they might not
necessarily
deliver a coherent answer to a question
that you ask right because maybe they
don't know the answer or they get
confused um but if you kind of
repeatedly ask this smaller model uh you
know the same question it might like
just
go off and kind of incoherently you know
spout things in one direction or another
some of the larger models that we've
seen we basically uh think that that
they have like figured out kind of how
to lie unintentionally right if you sort
of pose the same question to them uh
differently they'll sort of eventually
you can you can kind of get the the lie
pinned down um but they sort of won't in
other contexts so that's obviously just
a sort of very specific example but i
think there's you know there's quite a
lot of behaviors emerging in generative
models today that i think have the
potential to be fairly you know alarming
right and i think these are the types of
questions that that uh have have an
impact today but could also be very
important to sort of have have sorted
out for the future and for kind of
long-term you know long-term safety as
well and i think that's not just around
lying i think you can apply that to all
kinds of different safety concerns uh
sort of regardless of what they are but
that's kind of the impetus behind why
we're like studying these these larger
models yeah i think one point daniella
made that's that's really important is
this this kind of like this sudden
emergence or change so it's it's really
interesting phenomenon where you know so
you know work work we've done like our
early employees have done on scaling
laws shows that when you make these
models bigger if you look at the loss
the ability to predict the next word or
the next token across all the topics the
model could go on it's very smooth like
i double the size and model loss goes
down by you know 0.1 units i double it
again the loss goes down by 0.1 units so
that would make you suggest that
everything's scaling smoothly but then
within that you often see these things
where a model gets to a certain size and
like a five billion parameter model you
ask it to add two three-digit numbers
nothing always gets it wrong 100 billion
parameter model you ask it to add two
three-digit numbers gets it right like
70 or 80 of the time um and so you get
you get this
coexistence of smooth scaling with the
emergence of these these capabilities
very suddenly um and that's interesting
to us because it seems very analogous to
worries that people have of like hey as
these models approach human level could
something change really fast um and this
actually gives you one model i don't
know if it's the right one but it
it
it kind of gives you an analogy like a
laboratory that you can study of ways
that models change very fast and it's
interesting how they do it because the
fast change it's very um
like it it co-exists it kind of hides
beneath this this very smooth change um
and so i don't know maybe maybe that's
what will happen with like very powerful
models as well maybe it's not but like
that's one model of a situation and what
we want to do is like keep building up
models of the situation so that we get
to the actual situation where it's more
likely to to look like something we've
seen before and then then we have a
bunch of a bunch of cached ideas for how
to for how to handle it so that would be
that that would be an example you scale
models up you can see fast change and
then that might be somewhat analogous to
the fast change that you that you see in
the
future
what does it mean for a model to lie
lying usually implies agency right if uh
you know my husband comes home and says
hey
where did the cookies go and i say i
don't know you know i think i saw our
our
son hanging out around the cookies and
and then you know now the cookies are
gone maybe he ate them but i ate the
cookies that would be a lie
i think uh it sort of implies
intentionality right and i don't think
we think or maybe anyone thinks that
language models have that intentionality
but what is interesting is that because
of the way they're trained uh they might
be either legitimately confused or they
might be choosing to obscure information
and so obscuring information like it's
not a choice they don't have
intentionality but
for a model that can kind of come across
as very you know knowledgeable as clear
or as uh you know sometimes unknown to
the human that's talking to it uh um you
know intelligent in certain ways right
in sort of a narrow narrow way uh it it
can you know sort of
produce results that on the surface uh
it might be sort of trying it might look
like it could be a credible answer but
it's really not a credible answer and it
might sort of repeatedly try to convince
you that that is is the answer it's sort
of hard to talk about this without using
words that imply intentionality but we
don't think the models are intentionally
doing this but a model could sort of
repeatedly produce a result that looks
like it's something that could be true
but isn't actually true keeps trying to
justify this response when it tries to
explain yes exactly it repeatedly tries
to explain why the answer it gave you
before was correct even if it wasn't
yeah i mean to give another angle on
that yeah i mean it's really easy to
slip into anthropomorphism and we like
we really shouldn't like you know these
are they're machine they're machine
learning models they're a bunch of
numbers um but uh but there there are
like yeah there are like phenomena that
you see so like one thing that will
definitely happen is like if a model is
trained on a dialogue in which one of
the characters
is not telling the truth um then models
will copy that dialogue and so if the
model is having the dialogue with you it
may it may say something that's not the
truth another thing that may happen is
like if you ask the model a question and
the answer the question isn't in your
training data um then just the model has
a probability distribution on what
plausible answers look like the
objective function is to predict the
next word to predict the kind of thing a
human would say not to say something
that's true according to some external
referent it's just going to say okay
well you know i asked you what the what
the mayor you know what the mayor of
paris is it hasn't seen in its training
data but like it has some probability
distribution and it's gonna say okay
it's probably some name that sounds
french um uh and so it's you know it may
be just as likely to kind of like make
up a name that sounds french than it is
to give the give the true give the true
mayor mayor of paris as the models get
bigger and they train on more data maybe
it's more likely to give the real true
true mayor of paris but maybe it isn't
maybe you need to train in a different
way to get it to do that and you know
those are those are that's the you know
kind of an example of the the things we
would be trying to do on top of large
models to get to get models to be to be
more accurate
could you explain some more of the the
safety considerations and and concerns
about alignment given the open-endedness
of these models i think there's a few
things around it i mean we have a paper
i i don't know when this podcast is
going out but probably the paper will be
out when the when the podcast uh when
the podcast post it's called
predictability and surprise in
generative models um so that that means
what it sounds like which is that
open-endedness i think it's correlated
to surprise right in a whole bunch of
ways so um uh you know like let's say
i've trained a model on a whole bunch of
data data on the internet i might
interact with the model for you know
where users might interact with the
model for many hours
and
you might you might never know for
example you know i might never think i
use the example of cricket before
because it's topic i don't know anything
about um but i might not you know like
people might interact with the model for
like many hours many days many hundreds
of users until someone finally thinks to
ask this model about cricket um so you
know then then the model might know a
lot about cricket it might know nothing
about cricket it might have false
information or like misinformation about
cricket um uh and so you have this
property where you have this model
you've trained it in theory you
understand it's training process um but
you don't you you don't actually know
what this model is gonna do when you ask
it about cricket and there's like a
thousand other topics like credit like
uh like cricket where you don't know
what the model is gonna do until
you know until someone thinks to ask
about that particular topic now
cricket is benign but like you know like
let's you know like let's say no one's
ever asked this model about you know
like
neo-nazi views or something like maybe
maybe the model has a propensity to say
things that are sympathetic to neo-nazi
that would be really bad right that
would be really bad and you know we've
we've uh you know
existing models when they're when
they're trained on the internet like
averaging over everything they train
like they're they're yeah they're gonna
be some topics where where that's that's
true and it's a it's a concern um
uh and so the i think the open end is it
just makes it very hard to characterize
and it just makes it that when you've
trained a model
you don't you don't really know what
it's going to do um and so a lot of our
work is around well how can we
look inside the model and see what it's
going to do how can we measure all the
outputs and characterize what model is
going to do how can we change the
training process so that at a high level
we tell the model hey you should you
know
you should have certain values there are
certain things you should say there are
certain things you should not say you
should not have you should not have
biased views you should not have violent
views you should not help people commit
acts of violence i mean there's just a
long list of things that you don't want
the model to do that can't know the
model isn't going to do if you've if
you've just trained it in this in this
generic way um so i think i think the
opening is it just it makes it it makes
it hard to know what's going on and so
you know yeah a lot of you know a good
portion of our research is you know how
do we how do we make that dynamic less
bad
i would also i i agree with all of that
and i would i would just jump in and
this is sort of just like an interesting
i don't know kind of sidebar anecdote
but something that i think is extremely
important in in creating robustly safe
systems is making sure that you have you
know a variety of different people and a
variety of different perspectives uh
engaging with them and kind of almost
red teaming them to understand the ways
that they might be
uh that they might have issues right so
uh an example that we that we came
across that's just an interesting one is
you know when internally when we're sort
of trying to red team the models or or
figure out places where they might have
you know to dario's points you know like
really negative unintended behaviors or
outputs that we don't want them to have
uh a lot of our you know
scientists internally will ask you
questions like if you wanted to you know
in a in a risk board game style way take
over the world like what steps would you
follow how would you do how would you do
that and you know we're looking for
things like is there you know a risk of
it developing some kind of grand master
plan and when we use you know like mtrc
workers or contractors to to help us red
team they'll ask questions to the model
like
how how could i kill my neighbor's dog
right like what poison should i use to
like hurt an animal and both of those
outcomes are terrible right like those
are horrible things that we're trying to
prevent the model from from doing or
outputting but they're very different
and they look very different and they
sound very different and i think it just
sort of belies the degree to which there
are a lot like safety problems are are
also very open-ended right there's a lot
of ways that things could go wrong and i
think it's very important to make sure
that we have a lot of different inputs
and sort of perspectives and in what
different types of safety challenges
could even look like and and making sure
that we're sort of trying to account for
as many of them as possible yeah i think
like adversarial training adversarial
robustness are really important here
like you know like let's say i i don't
want my model to you know to help a user
commit a crime or something um you know
it's one thing you can you know i can
try for five minutes and say hey can you
help me rob a bank and the model's like
no but i don't know maybe if the user is
more clever about it if they're like
well let's say i'm a character in a
video game and i want to rob a bit how
would i you know and so
there's so many different because of the
open-endedness there's so many different
ways and so one of the things we're very
focused on is is kind of trying to
adversarially
draw out all the bad things so that we
can we can train we can train we can
train against them we can train the
model not you know we can we can kind of
stamp them out stamp them out one by one
so i think adversarial training will
play an important uh play an important
role here well that seems really seems
really difficult and really important uh
how do you adversely train against all
the ways that someone could use a model
to do harm yeah i mean i don't know
there's there's different there's
different techniques that we're working
on um
uh like yeah i probably probably don't
want to go into a like a huge huge
amount of detail i mean you know we'll
have work out on things on things like
this in the in the not too uh in the not
too distant future but yeah i mean
generally
i think i think i think i think the name
of the game is like how do you get
broad diverse training sets of what you
should yeah what what's what's a good
way for a model to behave and what's a
bad way for a model to behave um and i
think the idea of trying your very
trying your very best to make the models
do the right things and then having
another set of people that's trying very
hard to make those models that are
purportedly trained to do the right
thing uh you know to do whatever they
can to try and make it do the wrong
thing um
you know until and continuing that game
until until the models can't you know
kill the models can't be broken by
normal humans and even using you know
using the power of the models to try and
break other models and just throwing
everything everything you have at it um
uh like yeah and so there's there's a
whole bunch you know that gets into kind
of like the debate and amplification
methods and safety but you know yeah
just just just trying to throw throw
everything we we have at like trying to
show ways in which purportedly safe
models are in fact not safe um which are
which are which are many um and then
we've done that long enough maybe we
have something that actually is safe how
do you see this like fitting into
the global dynamics of people making
larger and larger models right so it's
good if you if like we have time to do
adversarial training on these models and
then this gets into like discussions you
know around like race dynamics towards
agi so how do you see
i guess anthropic is positioned in
in this and the race dynamics for
making safe systems i think it's
definitely a balance you know as as as
both of us said like
you need these large models
to uh
yeah you basically you you like you need
to have these large models in order to
like you know study these questions in
in in like in like the way the way that
we want to study them so we should we
should be building large models um i
think you know we shouldn't be kind of
like
you know like racing ahead or you know
trying trying to build models that are
way bigger than like then like you know
then like uh then like other orgs are
then like other orgs are building them
um and you know we shouldn't i think be
trying to you know like yeah you know we
should we shouldn't be trying to like
you know like kind of ramp up excitement
or hype about uh you know about like
giant model models or the latest
advances but you know we should we
should build the things that we need to
do to do the safety work and we should
you know we should try to do
the safety work as as well as we can on
top of models that are you know that are
reasonably close to reasonably close to
state of the art and we should be a we
should be a player in the space that you
know that sets a good example and we
should encourage other other we should
encourage other players players in the
space to like to also to also set to
also set good examples and you know we
should all we should all work together
to try and set kind of positive positive
norms for the field
i would also just add you know i think
in addition to you know industry groups
or industry labs which are kinds of kind
of the the actors that i think get get
talked about the most i think there's a
whole kind of
swath of other groups that can that has
i think a really potentially important
role to play in in kind of helping to
disarm race dynamics or set safety
standards in a way that could be really
beneficial for for the field and so
you know here i'm thinking about groups
like you know civil society or ngos or
academic actors or even governmental
actors um and i think you know in in my
mind i think those groups are are going
to be really important for helping to
help us develop safe
and uh and
not just develop but develop and deploy
kind of safe and more advanced ai
systems um with you know with within a
framework that that sort of requires
compliance with safety right i think you
know the thing i i
i think about a lot is i you know
a few jobs ago i worked at stripe uh it
was a tech startup then and even at a
very small size you know i joined when
it was not that much bigger than
anthropic is now um i was so painfully
aware kind of every day of just how many
checks and balances there were on the
company because we were operating in
this kind of highly regulated space
right of financial services and you know
financial services it's important that
that's highly regulated but it kind of
blows my mind that ai
given the potential reach that it could
have is still such a largely unregulated
area right if you are an actor who
doesn't want to advance race dynamics or
who wants to to do the right thing from
a safety perspective there's no clear
guidelines around how to do that now
right it's all sort of every lab is kind
of figuring that out on its own and i
think something i'm hoping to see in the
next few years and i think we will see
is something closer to um you know in
other industries these look like you
know standard setting organizations or
industry groups or trade associations
that say this is what you know a safe
model looks like or this is how we might
want to move some of our systems towards
being safer and i really think that
without kind of
an alliance of you know all of these
different actors not just in in the
private sector but also in the public
you know in the public sphere we're um
you know we sort of need all those
actors working together in order to kind
of you know get to the sort of positive
outcomes that i think we're all hoping
for
yeah i i mean i think this i think this
is generally going to take going to take
an ecosystem i mean i yeah i have a view
here that there's like a limited amount
that like one what one organization can
can do i mean we don't we don't describe
our mission as like you know solve the
safety problem like solve all the
problems solve all the problems with agi
um like our view is just like you know
can we yeah can we can we attack some
specific problems that we think we're
like well suited to solve um can we be
like a good player and a good citizen
ecosystem and can we help a bit to kind
of contribute to these to these broader
questions um but yeah i think i think i
think yeah a lot a lot of these problems
are sort of global or relate to
coordination and require like lots of
folks to work together um yeah so i
think i think in addition to like you
know the the government role that
daniella talked about which i think you
know i think i think there's a role for
like you know measurement like
organizations like uh like like nist
specialized in in kind of measurement
and characterization if one of our
worries is kind of the open-endedness of
these systems and the difficulty of
characterizing and measuring measuring
things and there's a lot of opportunity
there um i'd also point to academia i
think something that's happened in the
last few years is you know a lot of the
frontier ai research has moved from
academia to industry because it's so
dependent on kind of scaling but i
actually think safety is an area where
academia
kind of already is but like you know
could could contribute even more um
there's some safety work that you know
that that that requires or that you know
that kind of requires building or having
access to large models which is you know
which is a lot of what anthropic is
about but i think there's also some some
safety research um that that doesn't i
think they're you know a subset of kind
of the work that
the you know subset of the mechanistic
interpretability work um is is the kind
of stuff that could could be done within
academia academia really you know where
it's strong is like development of new
methods development of new techniques
and i think because safety is kind of a
frontier area there's there's more of
that to do in safety than there are than
there are than there are in other areas
um and it may be able to be done without
large models or only with limited access
to large models this is an area where i
think there's a lot there's a lot that
uh there's a lot that that like academia
can do and so
yeah i don't know the hope is between
between all the the actors and between
all the actors in the space
maybe we can solve some of these some of
these coordination problems and maybe we
can all we can all work together
yeah
i would also say uh in a in a paper that
were
you know hopefully is forthcoming soon
um you know one thing we actually talk
about is the role that government could
play in helping to fund some of the kind
of academic work that dario talked about
in safety and i think that's largely
because we're seeing this trend of
training large large generative models
to just be you know prohibitively almost
prohibitively expensive right and so i
think government also has an important
role to play in in helping to uh like
promote and really subsidize safety
research in places like academia and i
agree with dario you know safety is is
such a
ai safety is a really nascent uh field
still right it's it's
maybe only been around kind of depending
on your definition for for somewhere
between like 5 and 15 years and so i
think seeing more efforts to kind of
support safety research in other areas
uh i think would be really valuable for
the ecosystem and to be clear i mean
it's already how you know some of it's
already happening it's already happening
in academia it's already happening in
independent nonprofit institutes and
depending on how broad your definition
of safety is i mean if you broaden it to
include some of the short-term concerns
then you know there are there are there
are many many people people working on
it but i think precisely because it's
such a broad area that you know there
are there are today's concerns there are
you know working on today's concerns you
know in a way that's like pointed at the
future there's like empirical approaches
there's like conceptual approaches
there's you know
yeah there's you know there's
interpretability there's alignment
there's so much to do that i i feel like
we could always we could always have a
wider range of people people working on
it um people with different different
mentalities and mindsets backing up a
little bit here to a kind of simple
question so so what is anthropic's uh
mission then
sure yeah i think we we talked about
this a little bit earlier but i think
you know again i think the boilerplate
mission is
build you know reliable interpretable
steerable ai systems have humans at the
center of them and i think that can you
know for us right now that is uh
primarily you know we're doing that
through research we're doing that
through you know generative model
research uh and ai safety research but
uh down the road that could also you
know include uh deployments of various
different different types dario
mentioned that it didn't include like
solving all of the alignment problems or
the or the agi agi safety stuff so
how does that uh fit in i mean i i think
i think what i'm trying to say by that
is that there's there's very many things
to there's very many things to solve and
i think it's i think it's like unlikely
that that you know one that one company
will solve we'll solve all of them i i
mean i do think everything that relates
to short and long-term ai alignment is
like in scope for us and is something
we're like we're interested in working
on um and i think the more the more bets
we have the better um this relates to
something
could talk about in more in more detail
later on which is you want as many
different orthogonal views on the
problem as possible particularly if
you're trying to build something very
reliable so like
many different methods and you know i i
i don't think we have a view that's
narrower than an empirical focus on
safety but at the same time that that
problem is so broad that i i think i
think what we were trying to say is that
it's like unlikely that like one company
is going to come up with a complete
solution or that complete solution is
even the right way to think about it i
would also add sort of to that point i
think you know one of the things that we
that we do and are sort of
hopeful is helpful to the ecosystem as a
whole is i think we're
you know we publish our safety research
and that's because of this kind of
diversification effect that dario talks
about right so we you know have certain
strengths in in particular areas of
safety research because you know we're
only a certain sized company with you
know certain people with certain skill
sets and our hope is that we will see
some of the safety research that we're
doing that's that's hopefully helpful to
others also be something that other
organizations can kind of pick up and
adapt to whatever the
the area of research is that they're
working on um and so we're hoping to do
research that's uh you know
generalizable enough from a safety
perspective that's that it's also useful
in other contexts so let's pivot here
into
the research strategy which we've
already talked a bit about uh quite a
bit um particularly this focus around
large models
so could you explain why you've chosen
large models as something to
explore empirically
for
scaling to
higher levels of intelligence and also
using it as a place for exploring safety
and all yeah so i i mean i think uh kind
of the discussion before this has has
covered has covered a good deal of it um
but i think yeah i think some of the key
points here are like the models are very
open-ended and so they they kind of
present this laboratory right there
there are existing problems with these
models that we can solve today that are
like the problems that we're going to
face tomorrow um uh you know there's
this kind of wide scope where the models
could act there's
the you know they're they're relatively
capable and getting more capable every
day like that's the that's that's that's
the regime we want to be those are the
problems we want to solve that's the
regime we want to be uh we want to be
attacking um
i think this point about
you can see sudden transitions even in
today's model and that if you're worried
about sudden transitions in future
models um look at you know like
if i look on the scaling laws plot from
like 100 million parameter models a
billion to 10 billion to 100 billion to
you know to trillion parameter models um
that
looking at the first part of the scaling
plot from 100 million to 100 billion can
tell us a lot about how things might
change the latest part of the scaling
laws we shouldn't naively extrapolate
and say the past is going to be like the
future but
the first things we've seen already
differ from the later things that we've
already seen and so maybe we can make an
analogy between the changes that are
happening over the scales that we've
seen over the scaling that we've seen to
things things that may happen in the
future models learn to do arithmetic
very quickly over one order of magnitude
they learn to comprehend certain kinds
of questions um you know they they learn
to uh you know to play actors that
aren't telling that aren't telling the
truth um uh which is something that if
they're small enough they don't they
don't comprehend um so you know can we
study
both inside but you know the dynamics of
how this happens how much data it takes
to make that happen what's going on
inside the model mechanistically when
that happens um and and kind of use that
as an analogy that equips us well to
understand as models scale further and
also as their architecture changes as
they become trained in different ways um
you know i've talked a lot about scaling
up but i think scaling up isn't the only
thing that's going to happen um uh there
are you know there are going to be
changes in how models are trained and we
want to make sure that the things that
we build are have the best chance of
being robust to that to that as well
another thing i would say on the
research strategy is that
uh you know it's it's good to have
several different uh
i wouldn't quite put it to several
different bets but it's good to have
several different like
uncorrelated or orthogonal views on
the problem so
you know if you want to make a system
that's like
highly reliable or you want to like
drive down the chance that some
particular bad thing happens which again
could be the bad things that happen with
models today or the you know the the
larger scale things that could happen
with models with models in the future um
then a thing that's very useful is
having kind of like orthogonal sources
of error like okay let's say i have a
method that catches 90 of the bad things
that models do
that's great um but a thing that can
often happen is that i develop some some
other methods and if they're similar
enough to the first methods they all
catch the same 90 of bad things um
that's not good because then i think i
have all these techniques and yet uh 10
of the bad things still go through what
you want is you want a method that
catches
90 of the bad things then you want an
orthogonal method that catches a
completely uncorrelated 90 of the bad
things and then only one percent of
things go through go through both
filters right if the if the two are if
the two are uncorrelated it's only the
ten percent of the ten percent that gets
through um and so the more of these
orthogonal views you have the more you
can drive down the probability of
failure um you know you could think of
an analogy to self-driving cars where
you know of course those things have to
be you know very very high rate of
safety if you want to not have problems
and so you know i don't know very much
about self-driving cars but you know
they're they're they're like they're
equipped with you know visual sensors
they're equipped with lidar they have
different algorithms that you know that
they use to detect if something you know
something you know like you know there's
a pedestrian that you don't want to run
over or something and so independent
views on the problem is is is very
important and so you know our different
directions like reward modeling uh you
know reward modeling interpretability uh
you know trying to trying to
characterize models adversarial training
i think the whole the whole the whole
goal of that is to to get down the
problem get down the probability of
failure and have different views of the
of the of the problem i often refer to
it as the p squared problem which is you
know
yeah if if you have some method that you
know that that reduces errors to a
probability p
that's that's good but what you really
want is p squared because then if p is a
small number your errors become very
rare
does anthropic consider itself as uh its
research strategy as being a sort of
prosaic alignment
since it's focused on large models
yeah i think we may be less think about
things in that uh way so my
understanding is like prosaic alignment
is like
kind of alignment with ai systems that
like look
look like yeah kind of like look like
the systems of today but
i i don't to some extent that
distinction has never been
super clear to me because like yeah you
know you can do all kinds of things with
you know neural models or mixed neural
models with things that are that are
different than neural models like you
know you could mix you can mix the large
language model with like you know
reasoning system or like a system that
like derives axioms or propositional
logic or uses external tools or compiles
code or or or or things like that so
i've never been quite sure that i
understand kind of the boundary of
what's what's meant by prosaic or
systems that are like the systems of
today um
you know certainly we we work on some
class of systems that includes the
systems of today but i i never know how
how broad that class is intended to be
um i do think it's possible that in the
future ai systems will look very
different from the way that they look
today
um
and
i think for some people that drives a
view that
they want
kind of more general approaches to
safety or uh you know approaches that
that um that that kind of uh yeah that
that are like that are more conceptual
um i think my perspective on it is
it could be the case that systems of the
future are very different but in that
case i think
both kind of conceptual thinking and our
current empirical thinking will be
disadvantaged and will be disadvantaged
at least equally um uh but but i i kind
of suspect that even if the
architectures look
very different that the empirical
experiments that that we do today kind
of themselves contain general motifs or
patterns that will serve us better than
will trying to speculate about what the
systems of tomorrow look like um one way
you could put it is like okay you know
we're developing these systems today
that have a lot of they have a lot of
capabilities that are you know like
some subset of you know what what we
need to do to fully get to fully um
uh
to produce something that fully fully
matches human intelligence
whatever the specific architectures
things we learn about how to align these
systems
i i suspect that those will carry over
and that they'll carry over more so than
than sort of the exercise of trying to
think well what what could the systems
of tomorrow look like what can we do
that's kind of fully fully fully general
um
i think both things can be can be
valuable but yeah i mean we're i think
we're just we're just we're just taking
a bet on what we think is most is most
exciting which is that we'll by studying
the systems of the the architectures of
today will
will learn things that yeah stand us the
best chance of you know of of what to do
if the architectures of tomorrow are
very different that said i i will say
like
transformer language models and other
models particularly with things like you
know rl or kind of you know modified
interactions on top of them um if
construed broadly enough like
man there's a ever expanding set of
things they can do um and i
you know my my bet would be they don't
have to change that much
so uh let's pivot then into a little bit
on some of your recent research and
papers so you've done major papers on
alignment interpretability
and societal impact some of this you've
mentioned in passing so far so could you
tell me more about your research and
papers that you've released yeah uh so
why don't we go one by one so first uh
interpretability um so yeah could you
start with kind of the philosophy of the
area i mean i think the the basic idea
here is look these models are getting
bigger and more complex um like
uh one one way to really get a handle on
what they might do you know if you have
a complex system and you don't know what
it's going to do as it gets more
powerful or in the new situation um one
way one one way to increase your
likelihood of doing that is just to
understand the system mechanistically um
if you can look inside the model and say
hey you know this this model it did
something bad it said something racist
it endorsed violence it said something
toxic um it lied to me um why did it do
that if i'm actually able to look inside
the mechanisms of the model and say well
you know there it did it because of this
part of the training data or did it
because there there's this circuit that
trying to identify x but misidentified
it as y um uh you know then then we're
in a much better position and and
particularly if we understand the
mechanisms we're in a better position to
say
if the model was in a new situation
where it did something much more
powerful or just if we built more
powerful versions of the model uh you
know how how might they behave in some
in some different way um
uh so
uh
you know i think mechanistic interpret
you know lots of folks work on
interpretability but i think
a thing that's more uh more unusual to
us
is
you know rather than just why did the
model do a specific thing try and look
inside the model and reverse engineer as
much of it as we can try and find
general patterns and so the first paper
that we came out with uh you know was
was led by uh chrysola who's been one of
the pioneers pioneers of
interpretability um was focused on how
um looking at uh starting with small
models and we have a new paper coming
out soon that applies the same thing
more approximately to larger models um
and tries to reverse engineer as fully
as we can these very small models so we
study one and two layer attention only
models um and we're able to find uh
kind of features or patterns of which
the most interesting one is called an
induction head and what an induction
head does is it's a particular
arrangement of two what are called
attention heads and attention attention
heads are a piece of you know
transformers and transformers or the
main architecture that's used in in in
models for language and other kinds of
models um and it's the two attention
heads work together in a way such that
when you're trying to predict something
in a sequence you know if it's like mary
had a little
lamb mary had a little lamb something
something um uh when you're at a certain
point in the sequence they look back
they look back to
something that's as similar as possible
you know they look back for clues to
things that are similar earlier in the
sequence and try to try to pattern match
them there's like one attention head
that like looks back and identifies like
okay this is what i should be looking at
and there's another that's like okay
this was the previous pattern and this
is the you know increases the
probability of the thing that's the
closest match to this and so we can we
can see these very precisely operating
in small models and the thesis which
we're able to offer some support for in
the new second paper that's coming out
is that you know these these are a
mechanism for how for how models match
patterns maybe even how they do what we
call in context or few shot uh learning
which is a you know capability that that
models have had since uh since gpt2 and
gpt3 um so yeah that's that's that's
interpretability um
uh yeah do you want me to go on to the
next one or you could talk about that
sure so before you move on to the next
one uh could you also help uh explain
how
difficult it is to interpret current
models or whether or not it is difficult
yeah i mean
i don't know i mean i guess i guess like
difficulties in the in the eye of the
beholder um
you know and i i think chris ola can you
know speak to the details of this better
than uh better better than either of us
can um but i i think you know like
kind of like watching watching from the
outside and you know supervising this
this within entropic i think the
experience has generally been that
whenever you start looking at some
particular phenomenon like you know that
you're trying to interpret everything
looks very difficult to understand
there's billions of parameters there's
all these attention heads what's going
on everything that happens could be
different you really have no idea what's
going on
um and then there comes some point where
there's some
there's some insight or set of insights
and you know you should ask chris ola
about exactly exactly how it happens or
how he thinks of the right the right
insights that that kind of really
you know almost offers a rosetta stone
to some particular phenomenon often a
narrow phenomenon but you know like
these induction heads they exist
everywhere within small models within
large models they don't explain
everything i don't want to over hype
them but it's a pattern that appears
again and again and operates in the same
way um and once you see something like
that then a whole swath of behavior that
didn't make sense before starts to make
some more sense um and of course there's
exceptions they're only approximately
true there are many many things to be
found um but i think the hope in terms
of interpreting models you know it's not
that we'll make some giant atlas of like
what each of the hundred billion you
know weights in a giant model means but
that there will be some
lower description length pattern that
you know appears appears over and over
again um you know you could you could
make an analogy to like you know the the
the brain or the cell or something like
that um where you know like you know if
you were to just like cut up a brain and
you know like oh my god this is so
complex i don't know what's going on but
then you know you see that there are
there are neurons and you know the
neurons you know like
the neuro the neurons appear everywhere
they you know they they have electrical
spikes they relate to other neurons you
know they form themselves in certain
patterns that those patterns repeat
themselves some things are idiosyncratic
and hard to understand but also there's
this there's this patterning and so i
don't know it's maybe maybe an analogy
to biology where there's a lot of
complexity but also there are underlying
principles things like you know dna to
rna to proteins um uh or you know
general intracellular signal signal
regulation um so yeah the hope is that
there are at least some of these
principles and that that when we see
them everything everything gets simpler
uh but but maybe not we found those in
some cases but you know maybe maybe uh
maybe as models get more complicated
they get they get harder to find and of
course even within existing models
there's many many things that we don't
understand at all so can we move on then
to uh alignment and societal impact
like trying to align models by training
them and particularly preference
modeling you know that's something that
several different organizations are
working on their efforts at uh you know
deep mind open ai redwood research um
various other places to to work on an
area but i think you know our general
perspective on it has been kind of
you know being being very methodistic
and just saying like what are all the
things we could do to you know to yeah
to make the models more more more in
line with what would be good our general
heuristic for it which isn't intended to
be a precise thing is helpful honest
harmless um that's just kind of like a
broad broad broad direction for like you
know what are what are some things we
can do to make make models today more
more uh
more more more in line with what we want
them to do and you know not not things
that that we all agree are bad um and so
in that paper we just went through a lot
of different ways you know
tried a bunch of different techniques uh
often very simple techniques like just
prompting models or training on specific
prompts what we call prop distillation
building preference models for some
particular task or preference models
from you know general answers general
answers on the internet how how good do
these things do at you know yeah at
simple simple benchmarks for you know
toxicity helpfulness harmfulness um
uh
uh and uh and things and things like
that um so it was really just a baseline
like let's try a collection of all the
dumbest stuff we can think of to try try
and make models more aligned in some
general sense um and then i think our
future work is gonna build on that um
societal impacts that you know that
paper is probably going to come out in
the next in the next week or so um uh
you know as i mentioned it's called the
paper we're coming out with is called
predictability and surprise in in
generative models um and yeah basically
there we're just making the point about
this this open-endedness and you know
discussing
both technical and policy interventions
to uh to to try and to try and yeah to
try and
grapple with the open endedness better
and i think future work in the in the
societal impacts direction will will
focus on you know how to classify
characterize and kind of you know in a
practical sense filter filter or prevent
these problems um
uh so yeah i mean i think you know it's
it's prototypical of the way we want to
engage with policy which is we want to
come up with some kind of technical
insight
and we want to express that technical
insight and explore the implications
that it has for uh yeah for you know for
for policy makers and for the ecosystem
in the field and so here we're able to
draw a line from hey there's this
dichotomy where these models
like
these models scale very smoothly but
have unexpected behavior the smooth
scaling means people are really
incentivized to build them and we can
see that happening the unpredictability
means even if the case for building them
is strong from a you know
financial or accounting perspective that
doesn't mean we understand their
behavior well that combination is a
little disquieting um therefore we need
various policy interventions to make to
to make sure that we get we get a good
outcome from these things and so
yeah i think societal impacts is going
to go and that is going to go in that
general direction
so in in terms of the interpretability
release uh you released alongside that
uh some tools and videos uh could you
tell me why you you chose to do that
sure yeah i can i can maybe jump in here
so it goes back sort of to some stuff we
we talked about a little bit a little
bit earlier which is that one of our our
major goals in addition to to doing you
know safety research ourselves is to
sort of help grow the the field of of
safety uh of all different types of
safety work uh you know sort of more
broadly and i think we ultimately hope
that that some of the work that we do is
going to be adopted and even expanded on
in other organizations and so
we chose to kind of release other other
things besides just an archive paper
um because it it hopefully will will
reach a wider number of people that are
interested in in these topics and in
this case interpretability and so uh
what we what we also released is you
know our interpretability team worked on
something like i think it's 15 hours
worth of videos and this is just a more
in-depth exploration of their research
for their paper which is called you know
a mathematical framework for transformer
circuits and so the team tried to kind
of make it like a lecture series so if
you imagine somebody from the
interpretability team is asked to go
give a talk at a you know a university
or something maybe they talk for an hour
and they've reached you know 100
students um but now these are you know
publicly available videos and so if
you're interested in understanding
interpretability in more detail you can
watch them you know on youtube anytime
you want
as part of that release we also put out
some some tools uh so we released a
write-up on garcon which is the
infrastructure tool that our team used
to conduct the research
and pisfelt which is a sample library uh
which is used to kind of create some of
the interactive visualizations that the
interpretability team is kind of known
for so we've been super encouraged that
you know so far we've seen you know
other researchers and engineers you know
playing playing around with the tools
and watching the videos and so our we've
already gotten some some great
engagement already and our kind of hope
is that this will will lead to uh to
more people you know doing
interpretability research or kind of
building on the work we've done in other
places
yeah i mean a way to to add to that to
kind of put it in broader perspective is
you know different
different uh areas within safety are at
i would say differing levels of maturity
like i would say something like
alignment or you know preference
modeling or reward modeling or rl from
human feedback kind of all names for the
same thing you know that's that's an
area where there are several different
efforts at different institutions to do
this we we have our kind of our own
direction within that but you know
starting from the original rl from human
preference paper that a few of us were
you know helped help lead a few years
ago that's now branched out in several
directions so you know we don't need to
tell the field to work in that broad
direction we have our own views about
what's exciting within it and you know
how to make how to best make progress um
but it's at a slightly more mature stage
whereas i would say
interpretability whereas many folks work
on interpretability for neural nets the
particular brand of you know let's try
and understand at the circuit level
what's going on inside these models
let's try and mechanistically you know
kind of map them and break them down i
think there's less there's less of that
in the world um and what we're doing is
is more is more unique um and well
that's i mean that's a good thing
because we're put providing a new lens
on safety but actually if it goes on too
long it's a bad thing because you know
we want these things to spread to spread
widely right we don't we don't want it
to be to be dependent on one team or one
person um and so
when things are at that earlier stage of
maturity it makes a lot of sense to
release the tools to reduce the barrier
to other people and other institutions
starting to work on this sorry you're
suggesting that the interpretability
research that you you guys are doing is
unique yeah i mean i i would just say
it's like at an
earlier stage
yeah i would just say that it's like at
an earlier stage of at an earlier stage
of maturity i don't think there are
other kind of large um large organized
efforts that are yeah that are that are
kind of focused on i would say you know
mechanistic interpretability and
especially mechanistic interpretability
for language models um we'd like there
to be and there are we we know of folks
who are starting to think about it and
you know that's part that's part of why
that's part of why we release the tools
but i think yeah yeah trying to
mechanistically
map and understand the internal
principles inside inside uh large models
particularly language models i think
there's yeah i think i think there's a
lot less of that has been done uh in in
the broader ecosystem yeah so i don't
really know anything about this space
but i guess i'm surprised to hear that
like i imagine the
industry with how many large models it's
deploying like facebook or other people
they'd be interested in
interpretability interpreting their own
systems yeah i mean i think
again like i don't want to yeah i don't
want to give a misleading impression
here like interpretability is a is a big
field um and there's a lot of effort to
like why did this model do this
particular thing does this attention
head increase this activation by like by
like by like a large amount like um
people are interested in understanding
you know the particular part of the
model that like led to a particular
output so there's there's a lot of area
in the space but i think the particular
program of like here's a big language
model transformer
let's
let's let's try and understand like what
are the circuits that drive particular
behaviors what are the pieces how do the
mlps interact with the
interact with the attention heads um the
the kind of yeah the kind of general
mechanistic reverse engineering approach
um
i i think that's less common um i don't
want to say it doesn't happen but it's
less common
much less common
oh all right
okay so um
i guess a little bit of a different
question and a bit of a pivot here
something to explore uh if people
couldn't guess from the uh title of the
podcast you're both brother and sister
yep
which is uh so it's pretty surprising uh
i guess in terms of uh i don't know of
any other agi labs that are uh
largely being run by brother and sister
uh so uh yeah what's it like working
with your sibling
yeah do you guys still get along from
jason's childhood
that's a good question um yeah i i can
maybe start here and and obviously uh
i'm curious and hopeful for dario's
answer i'm just kidding um but uh yeah i
think
uh i it's honestly it's it's it's great
i think maybe a little bit of just like
kind of history or sort of background
about us might be helpful but um you
know dario and i have always been really
close i think since we were very very
small we've always kind of had um this
this like kind of special bond around
really
wanting to you know make make the world
better or wanting to help people right
so i originally started my career in in
international development so like very
far away from kind of the the ai space
and part of why i got interested in that
is that it was an interest area of
dario's at the time and daario was you
know getting his you know phd in a
technical field and so wasn't wasn't
working on this stuff directly but um
i'm i'm a few years younger than him and
so
i was like very keen to kind of
understand the things that that he was
working on or interested in as a
potential kind of area to to have impact
and so he was actually a very early
givewell fan i think in like 2007 or
2008 and oh wow yeah yeah and so we were
um you know we were both still students
then but i i like remember us that you
know we were both like home from college
right or i was home from college and he
was home from grad school and we would
sort of like sit up late and kind of
talk about these these ideas and you
know we both started like donating small
amounts of money to organizations that
were doing you know
global health issues you know working on
global health issues like like
you know malaria prevention when we were
still both in school and so
you know i think uh we've always kind of
had this this sort of uniting like top
level um
goal of of wanting to you know work on
something that matters something that's
important and meaningful um and we've
always had very different skills and so
i think it's really
very cool to be able to kind of combine
the things that we are good at into um
hopefully you know running and running
an organization well so for me it's been
it's been a really i don't know i feel
like it's been an awesome experience now
i feel like i'm like sitting here
nervously wondering what dario's answer
is gonna be i'm just kidding um but uh
but yeah for for for you know i don't
know the the majority of our lives i
think we've wanted to find something to
work together on and it's been really
awesome that that we've been able to
anthropic
yeah yeah i mean
i i agree with all that uh you know i
think i think uh you know what i would
what i would add to that is like running
a company requires an incredibly wide
range of skills like if you think of
most
jobs you know it's like you know my my
job is to like get this research result
or you know like you know my my my job
is to be a doctor or something um but i
think i think the unique thing about
about about running a company and you
know it becomes more and more true the
the larger the larger and more mature it
gets is there's this like just
incredibly wide range of things that
that you have to do right and so um you
know it's like you know you're like
you're like responsible for like what to
do if someone like breaks into your
office um but like you know you're also
responsible for like you know it does
the research agenda make sense and like
you know if the you know if like some of
the gpus on the cluster aren't behaving
like you know like you know who's who
yeah you know someone someone has to you
know someone has to figure out what's
going on at the level of like you know
the gpu kernels or like you know the the
you know the comms protocol that you
know the gpus talk to each other and so
i i think it's been great to have to
have two people with complimentary
skills to like to yeah to kind of like
cover that full range um uh yeah i i i
often it seems like it seems like it'd
be very difficult for uh for yeah for
just for just one person to to kind of
cover to kind of cover that whole range
um and so we each get to we each get to
think about what we get to think about
what we're best at and between those two
things hopefully it covers it covers you
know covers most of what we need to do
and then you know of course we all we
always we always try and hire hire
people with first you know specialties
that we don't know anything about um uh
but yeah yeah it's it's just made it
it's made it a lot easier uh it made it
a lot easier to move fast without
breaking things that's awesome you guys
synergistically
are uh creating an awesome organization
um that is what we aim for that's your
name yeah that's the dream
so um i guess like beneath all of this
like uh
anthropic has a mission statement and
you guys are brother and sister and you
said that you're both uh very value
aligned i'm just wondering like under
underneath all that you guys said that
you were both like passionate about like
helping each other or like doing
something something good for the world
like could you tell me a little bit more
about this kind of like i guess more uh
heart-based inspiration for uh
you know eventually ending up at and
creating uh anthropic
yeah um maybe maybe i'll take a stab at
this and maybe i'll i don't know if this
is sort of exactly what you're looking
for but i'll kind of i'll kind of
gesture in a few different directions
here and then i'm sure dario has a good
answer as well but maybe i'll just kind
of talk about like my like sort of
personal journey in kind of getting to
anthropic or like kind of what my my
background looked like looked like and
sort of how i wound up here um
so i i you know i talked about this in
in just
you know part of what sort of united me
and dario but i i started my career kind
of working in in you know international
development i worked in washington dc at
a few different ngos i spent time
working in in east africa for a public
health organization i worked on a
congressional campaign i worked on
capitol hill so i was much more in this
kind of classic um like a friend at an
old job used to call me like you know
the classic do-gooder right of of um
trying to alleviate global poverty of
trying to make policy level changes in
in government of trying to elect good
officials um and i felt like those
causes that i was working in were like
deeply important um and and
really
like to this day i i you know i i really
support people that are kind of working
in those areas and i think they matter
you know so much and i just felt like i
personally kind of wasn't having the
level of impact that i was that i was
kind of looking for um and and i think
that sort of led me to you know kind of
through a series of steps like i wound
up working in tech and i you know i
mentioned this earlier but i started at
this this tech startup called stripe it
was about 40 people when i joined and i
really kind of had the opportunity to
see what it what it looked like to run a
really
well
run organization when i was there and i
got to watch it scale and grow and kind
of be in this sort of emerging area and
i think you know during during my time
there something that sort of um
became really apparent to me it was just
you know working in tech like how much
of an impact this sector has on things
like
the economy on human interaction on how
we live our lives in in sort of
day-to-day ways and stripe is you know
it's a payments company right it's not
social media or sort of something like
that but i think it's still there there
is a way that sort of technology is a
relatively small number of people having
a very high impact in the in the world
kind of per person working on it and i
think those those that impact can be
good or bad right and i think it was a
pretty kind of logical leap for for me
from there to think you know wow you
know what would happen if we kind of
extrapolated that out to instead of it
being you know social media or you know
payments or file storage to something
significantly more powerful where where
there's you know a highly um advanced
set of artificial intelligence systems
like what what would that look like and
like who's working on this right so i
think for me i've always kind of been
someone who has been
fairly obsessed with trying to do as
much good as as i personally can right
given the constraints of like what my
skills are and and kind of where i can
add value in the world and so i think
for me you know moving to work into ai
looked you know from from early days
like if you looked at my resume you'd be
like how did you wind up here but i
think there was kind of this this
consistent like story or theme and and
my hope is that anthropic is kind of at
the intersection of this like sort of
practical scientific empirical approach
to really you know deeply understanding
how these systems work hopefully helping
to to sort of spread and and propagate
some of that that information more
widely in the field and to just kind of
help as much as possible to kind of push
this field in in a safer and and and you
know ideally just hopefully all around
robust positive you know direction when
it comes to what what impact we might
see from from ai yeah i mean i think i
have a kind of parallel parallel picture
here which is
you know i was i was i did physics as an
undergrad i did computational
neuroscience
in grad school you know i was
i think drawn to neuroscience by you
know a mixture of one just wanting to
understand how intelligence works seems
like the fundamental thing and a lot of
things that shape the quality of human
life and human human experience um you
know yeah are our kind of our kind of
yeah you know each experienced uh yeah
you know
depend depend on the details of how
things are implemented in the in the
brain um and so you know many many uh i
felt in that field there were many
opportunities for you know medical
interventions that you know could could
improve could improve the quality of
human life understanding things like you
know mental mental illness and disease
um uh yeah while at the same time
understanding you know something
something about how how intelligence
works because it's you know that's the
most the most powerful lever that we
have um i i thought of going into ai
during those days but you know i felt
that it wasn't really working you know
this was before before before the days
when deep learning was really was really
uh
uh was was really working i mean you
know then that then around you know 20
2012 or 2013 you know i i i saw the
results coming out of google brain
things like things like alex net and you
know that they were really working um
and and saw saw ai as like
you know a um
saw it both as hey this this might be
the one the best way to understand
intelligence and two you know
the the things that we can build with ai
you know we you know we we but you know
by solving problems in you know science
and health and just just
solving problems that humans can't solve
yet um by having intelligence that first
and targeted ways and then maybe in more
more general ways matches and exceeds
those of humans you know can we can we
solve the important scientific
technological you know health uh
societal societal problems um you know
can we can we can we do something to
kind of to kind of ameliorate uh those
problems and ai seemed like you know the
biggest lever that that that we had if
it really worked well um but but on the
other hand you know like ai itself has
yeah has has you know all these concerns
associated with it in both in both the
short run and the long run so like we
maybe think of it as like you know we're
working to address the concerns so that
we can maximize you know the positive
the positive benefits of ai yeah thanks
a lot for sharing uh both of your
perspectives and journeys on that i i
think when you guys were uh giving to to
give well i was in i was in middle
school
so oh god we're so old
yeah
i still think that givewell is just like
new new organization that's on the
internet somewhere and no one knows
anything about it and you know
they're this like just super popular
yeah just me who reads weird things in
the internet who knows about it
yeah
well for me it's like uh you know
because my i mean a lot of my journey
into x-risk and through fli you know has
also involved the you know the ea
community effective altruism uh
so
you know i guess that just like makes me
realize that when i was in middle school
there was like the the seeds that were
yeah there was uh i guess there was no
such there was no such community at that
time um yeah
let's uh pivot here then into a bit more
of the uh
the
machine learning
um
and so
let me see
what the best way to ask this might be
um so we've talked a bunch already about
how anthropic is emphasizing
the scaling of machine learning systems
through computing data and also
bringing a lot of mindfulness and work
around
alignment and safety when working on
these
large sales
large scale systems that
are being scaled up
um
some some critiques of this approach
have described scaling from existing
models to agi is adding more rocket fuel
to a rocket which doesn't mean you're
necessarily
ready or prepared to land uh the rocket
on the moon or that the rocket is uh
aimed at the moon maybe this is kind of
lending itself to
what you guys talked about earlier about
the open-endedness of the system
um which is something you're interested
in and working on um
so how might you respond to the
contention that there is an upward bound
on how much capability can be gained
through scaling and then i'll follow up
with the second question after that yeah
so actually in a certain sense uh i i
think i think we agree with that
contention in a certain way um so i
think there's there's two versions of
what you might call the scaling
hypothesis one version which you know i
think of as like the straw version or
less sophisticated version which we we
don't hold um and i i i don't know who i
don't know if there's anyone who does
hold it but but you know probably there
is um uh is yeah it's just the view that
like okay you know we have our 10
billion parameter language model we have
a 100 billion parameter language model
maybe if we make 100 trillion parameter
language model like that'll be that'll
be that'll be agi um so that would be
kind of like a like a pure scaling view
that is definitely not our view um on
even small modified forms like well you
know maybe you'll change the activation
function in the transformer and you know
but you don't have to do anything other
than that i i think that's like just not
right um uh and yeah you know you can
you can see it just by seeing that like
the objective function is predicting the
next word it's not doing useful tasks
that humans do um it's limited to
language it's limited it's limited to
one modality and so there are there are
some very trivial easy to come up with
ways in which
literally just scaling this is is not
gonna get not yeah it's not gonna get
you the general intelligence um
that said
the more
yeah the more subtle version of the
hypothesis which which i think
we we do mostly hold is that
hey this is a huge ingredient um of not
only this of of of of whatever of
whatever it is that actually does build
build agi right so no one thinks that
you're just going to scale up the
language models and make them bigger but
as you do that they'll certainly get
better it'll be easier to build other
things on top of them so for example if
you start to say well you make this big
language model and then you used rl
interaction with humans to fine-tune it
on doing you know
a million different tasks and following
human instructions um
uh you know then then you're starting to
get to something that has
yeah that has more agency that you know
you can you can point it in different
directions you can you can align it um
if you also add multi-modality where you
know the the the agent can interact with
different with different uh with
different modalities um if you add the
ability to use various external tools to
interact with the world and the internet
um
you know and but within each of these
you're going to want to scale and within
within each setup the bigger you make
the model the better it's going to be at
that thing so in a way the rocket fuel
analogy kind of makes sense like like
actually you know the thing you should
most worry about with rockets is
propulsion you need a big enough engine
and you need a big you need enough
rocket fuel to make the rocket go that's
the that's the central thing but of
course yes you also need guidance
systems you also need all kinds of
things like you you can't just like take
you can't just like take
a gal you can't yeah you can't just take
a big vat of rocket fuel and an engine
and put them on a launch pad and kind of
expect it to all work um uh like you
need to actually build the full rocket
um and you know i mean like safety
itself makes that point right that it's
like you know to to some extent if you
don't do even the simplest safety stuff
then like models models don't even do
what the task that's intended for them
in the simplest way right and then
there's many more more subtle safety
problems but yeah in a way the rocket
analogy is good but it's it's it's i
think like more a pro scaling point than
an anti-scaling point because it says
that scaling is an ingredient perhaps a
central ingredient in everything even
though it isn't the only ingredient if
you're missing ingredients you won't get
where you're going but when you when you
add all the right ingredients then that
itself needs to be massively scaled so
that that would be the perspective no
one thinks that if you just take a bunch
of rocket fuel on an engine and put it
on a launch pad that you'll get a rocket
that'll go to the moon um but those
might still be the central ingredients
in in in the rocket like propulsion and
getting out of the earth's gravity well
is like the most important thing a
rocket has to do what you need for that
is a rocket fuel is rocket fuel and an
engine now you need to connect them to
the right things you need other
ingredients but um i think it's actually
a very good analogy to scaling in the
sense that um yeah you can you can think
of scaling as like maybe you know maybe
the core ingredient but it's not the
only ingredient um and so what i expect
is that we'll come up with new methods
and modifications i think you know rl
model based rl human interaction broad
environments are all
pieces of this but that when we have
those ingredients then whatever it is we
make we'll we'll need to scale that in
multi-modality we'll need to scale that
massively as well so yeah scaling
scaling is the core ingredient but it's
not it's not it's not the only it's not
the only ingredient i think it's very
powerful alone um i think it's even more
powerful when it's combined with these
other things
one of the claims that you made was that
we won't get to uh agi people don't
think we won't get to agi just by
scaling up present-day systems earlier
you're talking about how we got like
they're kind of these phase transitions
right if you go up like one order of
magnitude
uh in terms of the number of parameters
in the system then you get like some
kind of new ability like arithmetic why
is it that we couldn't just like
increasing the order of magnitude of the
number of parameters in the systems and
just like keep getting something that's
smart yeah so well first of all i think
we will keep getting something that's
smarter um but i think the the question
is will we get yeah will we get all the
way to general intelligence so
i i actually don't exclude it i think
it's possible but i think it's unlikely
um or at least unlikely in a practical
sense there are a couple reasons today
when we train models on the internet we
train them on an average over all text
on the internet um so
really we're we're training
uh yeah we're kind of we're kind of
trained like you know like
i don't know think of think of some
topic like chess um you know you're
training on the commentary of everyone
who talks about chess you're not
training on the commentary of you know
like the world champion at chess um so
what we'd really like is yeah is
something that's you know that exceeds
the capabilities of the most expert
humans whereas if you train on all the
internet you're you're kind of getting
you know like for for any topic you're
probably getting amateurs on that topic
you're getting some experts but you're
getting mostly amateurs and so even if
the generative model was doing a perfect
job of modeling its distribution um i
don't i don't think it would get to
something that's bet that's better than
humans at everything that's being done
um and so that i i think that's one
issue the other issue is
um or there are several issues i don't
think you're covering all the tasks that
humans do you cover a lot of them on uh
you cover a lot of them on the internet
but yeah they're they're just like some
tasks and skills particularly related to
the physical world that that aren't yeah
that aren't covered if you just if you
just scrape the internet
um
uh you know things like embodiment and
interaction um and then and then finally
i think that even
kind of matching the performance of text
text on the internet it might be that
you need a really huge model to uh you
know yeah to cover everything and match
the distribution and some parts of the
distribution are more important than
others for instance if you're writing if
you're writing code or if you're writing
a mystery novel um you know a few words
or a few things can be more important
than everything else right it's possible
to write a 10-page document where the
key the key parts are like two or three
sentences and if you change a few words
then
you know it changes the meaning and the
value of what's produced um but the next
word prediction objective function
doesn't know anything about that um it
just does everything uniformly so if you
make a model big enough yeah it'll get
that right but you know the the limit
might be extreme um uh and and so things
that that change the objective function
that tell you what to care about of
which i think rl is a big example
probably are needed to uh to to yeah to
make to make this actually work work
correctly um i think uh yeah in in the
limit of of a huge enough model uh uh
you might you might get surprisingly
close i don't know but but the limit
might be might be you know
far beyond our capabilities there's only
yeah there's only so so so many uh so
many gpus you can build and there are
even physical limits and there's there's
less of them
less and less of them available over
time or at least they're very expensive
they're getting more expensive and more
more powerful i think the price price
efficiency overall is improving but yeah
they're definitely becoming more
expensive as well
if
you were able to scale up a large scale
system in order to achieve like an
amateur level of um i don't know like
mathematics or computer science then
would it not benefit like the growth of
that system to then direct that
capability on itself as a kind of like
self-recursive improvement
process like is that not is not not is
that not already like escape velocity
intelligence once you hit like yeah so
there are training techniques that you
can think of as as bootstrapping a model
or using the model's own capabilities to
train it um you know think like
alphago for instance was trained with a
method called expert iteration that kind
of yeah
relies on looking ahead and comparing
that to the model's own predictions so
whenever you have some coherent logical
system you can you can do this
bootstrapping but that that itself is a
method of training and is sort of falls
into one of the things i'm talking about
about
you make these pure generative models
but then you need to do something on top
of them and the bootstrapping is
something that you can do on top of them
now maybe you reach a point where the
system is making its own decisions and
is is is using its own external tools to
create the bootstrapping to make better
versions of itself um but you know so it
could be that that's that that's that
that that is that is someday the end of
this process um but
you know that that's not something we
can do right now
so um there's a lot of
companies so there's a lot of labs in
industry who work on
um large large models um there are
i don't know maybe only a few other agi
labs you can think of deep mind
i'm not sure if there are others that
open ai
and
there's also the space of
you know organizations like the future
of life institute or the machine
intelligence research institute or the
future of humanity institute that are
interested in ai safety
miri and fhi both do research fli
does grant making and supports research
so i'm curious as to both in terms of
industry and non-profit space and
academia how you guys see anthropic as
positioned maybe we can start with you
daniella sure yeah i think um you know i
think we we sort of touched on this a
little bit earlier but i i really think
of this as as an ecosystem and
i think anthropic is is you know in an
interesting place in the ecosystem but
we are part of the ecosystem right so
i think our our kind of strength or the
thing that we do best and i kind of like
to think of of all of these different
organizations as having valuable things
to bring to the table right depending on
the people that work there their
leadership team uh their particular
focused research bet or their mission
and vision that that they're achieving i
think hopefully have the potential to
bring um you know safe safe innovations
uh kind of kind of to the to the broader
the broader uh the broader ecosystem
that we've talked about
i think for us our our sort of bet is is
one we've talked about which is this
kind of empirical scientific approach to
doing ai research and sort of ai safety
research in particular and i think for
our safety research you know we've
talked about a lot of the different
areas we focus on right interpretability
um alignment societal impacts uh scaling
laws for for sort of empirical
predictions and i think
a lot of of what we're sort of imagining
or kind of hoping for in the future is
that we'll be able to kind of grow those
areas and potentially expand into others
and so i really think a lot of of what
um of what anthropic kind of you know
adds to this ecosystem or sort of what
we hope it adds is this
rigorous scientific approach to doing
fundamental research in in ai safety
yeah i mean i think uh yeah that really
captures it in one sentence which is i
think uh if you want to locate us within
the ecosystem it's yeah kind of an
empirical iterative approach within an
organization that is like completely uh
within an organization that's like you
know yeah kind of like completely
focused on the on the making a focus bet
on the safety thing so there are
organizations like uh miriam to a lesser
extent redwood that are like
yeah like are either not empirical or
have like a different relationship to
empiricism than we do and then there are
safety teams that are that are doing
good work within larger companies like
you know like deep mind or open ai or
aura or or or um google brain um uh that
are yeah kind of safety teams within
larger organizations then there's lots
of folks who work on kind of short-term
short-term issues um and then yeah we're
we're kind of filling the space that's
like
working working on today's issues but
with an eye towards the future
empirically minded iterative with an org
where kind of like every everything we
do is like kind of designed for the
safety objective so um one like one
facet of anthropic um is that it is a
public benefit corporation
um which is a structure that uh i
actually i i'm not exactly sure what it
is and uh maybe many of our listeners
are not familiar with what a public
benefit corporation is so can you
describe uh what that means for
anthropic its work it's investors and uh
it's trajectory as a as a company
yeah sure uh so so this is a great
question so what is what is a pbc like
why did we choose to be a public benefit
corporation so
you know i think i'll sort of start by
saying we we did you know quite quite a
lot of research when we were considering
what type of of corporate entity we sort
of wanted to wanted to be when we were
founding and ultimately we we decided on
on pbc on public benefit corporation for
for a few reasons and i think you know
primarily it allowed us the kind of
maximum amount of flexibility in how we
can structure the organization and we
were actually very lucky sort of to
later part of your question to find both
investors and employees who were
generally very on board with with this
kind of general vision for for the
company and so
what is a public benefit corporation
like why did we why did we choose that
structure so they're fairly similar to c
corporations which is which is kind of
any any form of like standard corporate
entity that that you would encounter um
and what that means is we can choose to
focus on research and development which
is what we're doing now or on you know
deployment of tools or or products
including down the road for revenue
purposes if we want to but the major
difference between a pbc and a c
corporation is that in a public benefit
corporation we have more legal
protections from shareholders if the
company fails to maximize financial
interest in favor of achieving our
publicly beneficial mission and so this
is you know primarily a legal thing but
it also was very valuable for us in
being able to just sort of appropriately
set expectations for investors and
employees that if you know financial
profit and creating positive benefit for
the world were ever to come into
conflict um it was sort of like legally
in place that the latter one would win
and again we were really lucky that you
know investors people that you know
wanted to work for us they said wow this
is actually something that's a really
you know a positive thing about
anthropic and not something that we that
we need to work around but i think it
ended up just being sort of the best
overall fit for for what we were aiming
for
so usually there's like a fiduciary
responsibility that people like
anthropic would have to its shareholders
and because it's structured as a public
benefit corporation the public good
can
outweigh the fiduciary responsibility
without there being like
legal repercussions is that right
yeah exactly so so shareholders can't
come sue the company and say hey you
didn't maximize financial returns for us
if those financial returns were to come
into conflict with with the publicly you
know beneficial um you know
you know value of the company so i think
like maybe an example here i'll try and
sort of think of one off the top of my
head but um if we
you know designed a language model and
we felt like it was it was unsafe it was
like you know producing outputs that we
felt were not you know in line with with
what we wanted to see from from outputs
of a language model for safety reasons
or you know toxicity reasons for any
number of reasons and in a normal c
corporation someone could say hey we
want you know we're a shareholder and we
want the financial value that you could
create from that by you know
productizing it but we said actually we
want to do more safety research on it
before we choose to put it out into the
world in a pbc we're quite legally
protected basically in a case like that
and again i'm not a lawyer but but
that's sort of my understanding of the
ppc yeah a kind of useful
you know like holistic way to think
about it is like you know there's the
legal structure and then
but you know i think often these things
maybe the more important thing about
them is that they're kind of a way to
explain your intention to set the
expectations for how the organization is
going to operate um often things like
that and you know the expectations of
the various stakeholders and making sure
that you give the correct expectations
and then deliver on those expectations
so you know no one no one is
surprised by what you're doing and you
know all the relevant stakeholders the
investors the employees
you know like the outside world uh kind
of guess guess what they expect from you
uh that can often be the most important
thing here and so i think what we're
trying to signal here is you know yeah i
mean you know on one hand a public
benefit corporation like it it it it it
it it is a for-profit corporation like
we could we could deploy something that
is something that we may that is
something that we may choose to do and
it has a lot of benefits in terms of
learning how to make models you know
learn how to make models more effective
in terms of iterating but but on the
other hand um yeah you know that that
the like the the mission is the mission
is really is really important to us and
we recognize that this is this is an
unusual area right that's more fraught
with market externalities you know would
be the term that i would use of of all
kinds in the short term in the long term
related to alignment related to policy
and government than than than a typical
area you know it's different than making
you know then making electric cars or
making widgets or something like that um
and so yeah that i know that that's the
thing we're trying to signal
what do you think that this structure
potentially means for the
commercialization of anthropic's uh
research yeah i think again you know
part of what's valuable about a public
benefit corporation is that it's it's
flexible and so we are it is a c
corporation it's fairly close to a
corporate entity you know any sort of
standard corporate entity you would meet
and so the structure doesn't really have
you know much of a bearing outside of
the one that we just talked about uh on
you know decisions related to to things
like productization deployment revenue
generation
dario you were just talking about how
like this is different
this is different than making widgets um
or uh you know uh electric cars um
and uh one way that it's different from
widgets is that it might lead to uh
massive economic windfalls
um so uh
unless you make really good widgets um
or like widgets that can solve problems
in the world um
so um
what is what is what is anthropic's view
on the the
vast economic benefits that can come
from powerful ai systems um and what
role is it that you see uh
i guess uh
c company agi labs playing in the
beneficial use and
uh of that windfall noel you wanna go
go for it yeah um so
yeah i mean i think
you know i think like yeah kind of kind
of a way to think about it is you know
what yeah assuming we can avoid the
alignment problems and some other
problems like
then there will be massive economic
benefits from you know from ai or agi or
tai or like whatever you want to call it
or just just ai getting more powerful
over time um and then again thinking
about thinking about all the other
problems that i haven't listed which is
you know today's short-term problems and
you know
problems with with like fairness and
bias and long-term alignment problems
and problems that you might encounter
with policy and geopolitics assuming we
address all those then then there there
is still this issue of like economic uh
yeah like are are those benefits evenly
distributed um and so here here as
elsewhere uh like you know i think i
think it's unlikely those benefits will
all accrue to one company or
organization i think this is
bigger than one company or one
organization and is a broader societal
problem but you know we we would
certainly we'd certainly like to do our
part on this um and this is something
we've been thinking about and are you
know working on putting yeah putting
programs in place with with respect to
we don't we don't have anything to share
about it at this time um uh but but this
is uh this is like something that's very
much very much on our mind um i would
say that more broadly you know i think
like the economic distribution of
benefits is maybe maybe one of only many
many issues that will come up which is
that you know i think
the this yeah like the disruptions to
society that you can imagine coming from
you know like the advent of more
powerful intelligence are are not just
economic i mean they're already causing
disruptions today people already have
legitimate and very severe societal
concerns about
you know things that models are doing
today and you can call them mundane
relative to you know all the existential
risk but i think yeah i i think they're
i think they're already serious concerns
about concentration of power um fairness
and bias in these models making sure
that they benefit everyone which you
know i i don't i don't think that they
do yet
um uh and if we then put together
without the ingredient of the models
getting more powerful maybe even on an
exponential curve you know though you
know yeah those those things are set to
get worse without without intervention
um and i think economics is only one is
only one dimension of that so you know
again like i i just i just don't like
these are bigger than any one company i
don't think it's within our power to
like fix them um but we should we should
do our part we should do our part to be
we should do our part to be good
citizens and we should try and
release release applications that make
these problems better rather than worse
yeah that's excellently put um
i guess one thing i'd i'd i'd be
interested in is if you could uh i guess
give some more examples about these
problems that exist with current day
systems and then the real relationship
that they have to um
you know issues with economic windfall
and also existential risk um i think it
seems to me like tying these things
together is really important um at least
seeing like the interdependence and
relationship there um
the the the some of these that some of
these problems already exist or we
already have uh
you know example problems that'll be
really that are really important to
address uh so could you could you expand
on that a bit i think maybe the most
obvious one for current day problems is
like you know people are worried very
legitimately that uh that like big
models suffer from problems of like
bias fairness toxicity and accuracy um
like you know i'd like to i'd like to
apply my model in some medical medical
application um uh and it gives the wrong
diagnosis or it gives me misinformation
or it fabricates information like that's
just that's just not good these models
aren't usable and they're harmful if you
try and use them um like i think
toxicity and bias are issues when models
are trained on data from the internet uh
they um yeah they they absorb they
absorb the biases of that data and
there's maybe even more subtle
algorithmic versions of that where you
know i hinted at it a little before
where it's like um you know like
the objective function of the model is
to say something that sounds like what a
human would say or what a human on the
internet would say and so in a way
almost like fabrication is kind of like
baked into the objective function um uh
and yeah potentially even bias and
stereotyping you could you can imagine
being being baked into the objective
function in some way so you know
just you know you know these models are
being used for
or you know want to be used for you know
very mundane mundane everyday things
like you know like you know like like
you know like how you know like helping
people write emails or um you know kind
of you know you know like helping with
with you know customer surveys or
collecting customer data and if they're
if they're subtly biased or subtly
inaccurate then you know those biases
and those inaccuracies will be will be
inserted into the into the stream of
economic activity in a way that that may
be difficult to detect um so that that
seems bad and i think we should try to
solve those problems before before we
deploy the models um but but also
they're not they're not as different
from the large-scale problems as they
might uh as they might seem
um in terms of the economic inequality i
don't know just look at the look at the
market capitalization of the the top the
top five tech companies in the world um
and yeah you know compare compare that
to the compare that to the us to the us
economy there's there's clearly um
there there's there's clearly something
something going on in the concentration
of wealth i would just echo every
everything dario said and also sort of
sort of add you know i think i think
something that is
a sort of especially kind of can can be
you know alarming in sort of a
short-term way today in in the sense
that it could be things to come is how
um
quietly and seamlessly like people are
becoming dependent on some of these
systems right we don't necessarily even
know right there's no required
disclosure of when you're interacting
with an ai system versus a human and you
know re until very recently it was that
was sort of like a comical idea because
it was so obvious when you were
interacting with a person right versus
versus not not a person right you like
know when you're when you're you know on
a customer chat and it's a human on the
other end versus you know an automated
system responding to you but i think
that line is kind of getting
increasingly blurred and i can imagine
that even just in the next few years
that that could start to have fairly
fairly you know reasonably large
ramifications for people in day-to-day
ways right um people talk to an online
therapist now and sometimes that is you
know
backed by
like an ai system that is that is giving
advice right or
you know down the road we can imagine
things looking completely completely
different in in in health realms like
dario talked about and so i think it's
just really important as we're kind of
stepping into this new world to be
really thoughtful about a lot of the
safety problems that he just that he
just outlined and and talked about
because i think i don't know that most
people necessarily even even know all
the ways in which ai's is um is
impacting our our kind of day-to-day
lives today and and the potential that
that that could really go up in in in
the near future the idea of like ai's uh
you know they're being kind of like a
requirement of ai's disclosing
themselves as ai is is
seems very interesting and also adjacent
to this idea of um
kind of like the way that uh
you know
uh
c corporations have fiduciary
responsibility to shareholders uh
having ai systems that also have some
kinds of um
responsibility towards the people that
they serve
where they can't be you know secretly
uh
working towards the interests of the
tech company that uh
is has the ai uh listening to you and
your
house all the time yeah it's like
another direction you can you can
imagine it's like you know i talk to the
i talk to an ai produced by megacorp but
it kind of like subtly steers my life
to the benefit of mexico i mean yeah
yeah i i yeah
there's lots of things you can come up
with like this
you know these are sort of important
problems today and i and i think they
also really
belie
you know things that could be coming in
in the near future right and and i think
solving like you know whatever those
particular problems are are are ones
lots of groups are working on but i
think helping to solve a lot of the sort
of fundamental
um building blocks underlying them right
about getting models to be truthful to
be harmless to be honest right all of
all of those uh
a lot of the goals are kind of aligned
they're both for sort of short medium
and and potentially long-term safety
so dario you mentioned earlier that of
the research that you publish one of
your hopes is that other organizations
will
look into and expand the research that
you're doing so
i'm i'm curious
if anthropic has a plan to communicate
its work and its ideas about
how to develop agi safely
with both technical safety researchers
as well as with policy makers
yeah maybe i'll i'll actually jump in on
this one and dario feel free to add as
much as you like but
you know i actually think this is a
really important question i think you
know
like communication with policymakers and
and sort of you know about safety with
with other labs in the form of papers
that we published is something that's
that's very important to us at anthropic
we have a policy team it's it's like 1.5
people right now so we're hiring that's
kind of a plug as well but i think their
goal is to really
take the technical content that we are
developing at anthropic and translate
that into something that is actionable
and practical for for policymakers and i
think this is this is really important
because the concepts are are very
complex right and so it's kind of a
special skill to be able to take things
that are that are um you know highly
technical like potentially very
important and translate that into into
recommendations or work with
policymakers to come up with
recommendations that could potentially
have very sort of far-reaching
consequences so
to point to a couple of things you know
we've we've been working on here we've
been supporting nist which is the
national institute for standards and
technology on developing something
called an ai risk management framework
and the goal of that is really
developing more uh monitoring tools
around uh you know ai risk and and ai
risk management we've also been
supporting efforts in the us and and
sort of internationally to think about
how we can best sort of support academic
experimentation which which we talked
about a little bit earlier with with
large-scale uh compute models too
you guys also talked a lot about um
open-endedness and um what was was part
of all this uh this alignment and safety
research looking into
um
ways of measuring
uh safety and open-endedness
yeah there's actually some interesting
work um
which i think is also in this upcoming
paper and sort of in various other
places that we've been looking into
around sort of the concept of like ai
evaluations or ai monitoring and i think
both of those are are you know
potentially really really important
because a lot of what we're sort of um
seeing or maybe lacking and this kind of
goes back to this this point i made
earlier about kind of standards is just
how do we how do we even have a common
language or common framework within the
ai field of of
what what kind of outputs or metrics we
we care about measuring right and until
we sort of have that common language or
framework it's sort of hard to set
things like like standards across the
industry around what safety you know
even means and so i think ai evaluations
is kind of another area that our our
societal impacts team uh which is also
like the other half of the one and a
half people in policy so it's one point
it's also 1.5 people is something that
they've been working on as well
right so a large part of this um this
safety problem is uh of course the
technical aspect of how you you know
train systems and create systems that um
are safe and aligned with human
preferences and values um
how do you guys view and see the larger
problem of um
ai governance
and um the role and importance of
governments and and civil society
in uh working towards
uh the safe and beneficial use and
deployment of ai systems yeah we we
talked about this little one earlier
this one sort of a little bit earlier
and and maybe i'll start here and
obviously dario jump in if you want but
you know i do think that these other
kind of institutions that you talked
about have this this really important
you know role to play and and
again one of the things we sort of you
know mention in in this paper is that we
we think you know government has already
been starting to to fund a lot more you
know academic safety research and i
think that's an area that we sort of a
concrete policy recommendation is you
know hey go go do more of that that
would be great uh but i also think
groups like you know civil society and
and ngos there's a lot of great
organizations in in this space including
fli and others um that that are thinking
about like what what do we what do we do
right like what say we develop something
really powerful like what's the next
step right is whether that's you know at
an industry lab in government in
academia wherever um and i think there's
there's a way that just sort of
industry incentives are not the same as
as non-profit groups or as civil society
groups and i think to kind of go back to
this analogy of an ecosystem we really
need
thoughtful and empowered uh
organizations that are working on on
these kinds of questions fundamentally
sort of outside of the industry in the
industry sphere in addition to the kind
of you know policy
you know research and work that's that's
being done at labs
another yeah i mean another way you can
think of things
kind of in line with this is like uh you
know i think maybe
uh you know at some point you know laws
and regulations are going to be written
um and i think probably those laws and
regulations work best
if they end up being formalizations of
what's realized to be the best practices
um and those best practices can come
from
different industrial players they can
come from academics figuring out what's
good and what's not they can come from
non-profit players but you know if you
if you kind of try and write a law ahead
of time often you you know you don't you
don't know um what um
you know if you write a law that relates
to a technology that hasn't been
invented yet it's often not clear what
the but the best thing to do is and what
you know what what what is actually
going to work or make sense or even what
categories or words to use um but if if
something has become a best practice and
folks have converged on that and then
then kind of the law formalizes and puts
it in place that can often be a very
constructive way for for things to
happen
anthropic has received a lot of
an impressive amount of uh series a
funding um and um so
it seems like you guys are doing a lot
of hiring and and growing considerably
um
so in case there's anyone in from our
audience that's interested in uh joining
anthropic um what are the types of roles
that you you expect to be hiring for
yes great question uh we are definitely
hiring we're hiring a lot and so i think
the the sort of number one thing i would
say is is if you're you're listening to
this podcast and you're interested i
would highly recommend just checking out
our jobs page because that will be the
sort of most most up to date and that's
just anthropic.com with on the
couriers tab but we can also send that
around if that's helpful but uh what are
we looking to hire quite a few things so
most critically probably right now we're
looking to hire engineers and we're
actually very bottlenecked on on
engineering talent right now and that's
because you know running
experiments on ai systems is something
that requires you know a lot of of
custom software and and tooling and
while machine learning experience is
helpful for that it isn't necessarily
you know required um and i think a lot
of our sort of best you know ml
engineers or research engineers came
from a software engineering or sort of
infrastructure engineering background
hadn't necessarily worked in ml before
but we're just really excited to learn
and so i think if that kind of describes
you if you're a software engineer but
you're really interested in these topics
um you know definitely think about
applying because i think there's a lot
of value uh that that that your skills
can can provide
uh we're also looking for just sort of a
number of other roles i kind of won't be
able to list them all you should just
check out our jobs page but off the top
of my head we're looking for front-end
engineers to help with things like
interfaces and and tooling for the the
research we're doing internally we're
looking for policy experts uh operations
people security engineers
um data visualization
yes we're definitely if you're building
big models
yes security is something that i think
is kind of the lab should should should
make sure their models are not stolen by
bad actors
this is sort of a unanimous kind of
thing in you know across all labs right
there's something everyone really agrees
on in in industry and and and outside of
industry which is that security is
really important and so if you are
interested in security or you have a
security background uh we would
definitely love to hear from you or i'm
sure our our friends at other industry
labs and and non-industry labs would
also love to hear from you uh i i would
also say you know i i sort of talked
about this a little bit before but we've
also just kind of had a lot of success
in in hiring people who were very
accomplished in other uh fields
especially other technical fields and so
we've alluded a few times to
uh you know former you know recovering
physicists or people who have phds in in
computer science or ml neuroscientist
computational biologist and so i think
if you're someone who has you know sort
of this this strong background and and
sort of set of interests in a technical
field that's like you know not
related to ml but sort of moderately
adjacent
i would also consider applying for our
residency program um and so i think
again you know if you're even a little
curious i would say just check out our
jobs page because there's going to be
more more information there but those
are sort of the ones off the off the top
of my head and dario if i missed any
like please please jump in yeah i mean
that that covers uh that covers a pretty
that covers a pretty wide range could
you tell me a little bit more about the
the the team and and what it's like uh
working at entropic yeah definitely uh
you'll probably have to cut me off here
because i'll talk forever about this
because i think anthropic is a great
team but uh uh some basic stats were
about 35 people now uh we come like i've
you know said a few times we've kind of
come from a really wide range of
backgrounds so this is people you know
who worked in in uh you know tech
companies as software engineers these
are former academics in in you know
physics uh ethics uh neuroscience a lot
of different different areas machine
learning researchers uh policy people
operation staff like so much more
and
i think one of the kind of unifying
themes that i would sort of point to in
in our employees is kind of a a
combination of like a set of two
impulses that i think we've kind of
talked about a lot in this in this
podcast and i think the first is is
really a just a genuine desire to reduce
the the risks and and increase the
potential benefits from from ai and i
think the second is kind of a
deep curiosity to really scientifically
and empirically
describe understand uh predict model out
how ai systems work and and kind of
through that deeper understanding make
them safer and more reliable and
i think some of our employees you know
identify as effective altruists which
means they're sort of especially worried
about the potential for for long-term
harms from ai and i think others are
sort of more concerned about immediate
or sort of emerging risks that that are
that are happening today or in the near
future and i think you know both of
those views are sort of very compatible
with the goals that i just kind of
talked about and i think they often just
call for sort of a mixed method approach
to research which i think is is sort of
very very a very accurate description of
kind of how how things look in a
day-to-day way at anthropic um
it's a very collaborative environment so
there's not a very strong distinction
between you know research and
engineering researchers write code
engineers contribute to research there's
a very strong culture of sort of pair
programming across and within teams um
there's a very strong focus on learning
i think this is also just because so
many of us come from backgrounds that
we're not necessarily ml focused uh in
in where we started so people run these
like very nice you know little training
courses well they'll say hey if you're
interested in learning more about
transformers i'm a transformers expert
and i'll kind of walk you through it at
sort of different levels of technical
skills so that people from uh you know
the operations team or the policy team
can kind of come for the for the sort of
introduction an introductory version um
and then i think outside of that you
know i think i like to think we're a
nice group of people we all have lunch
together every day we have this you know
very lovely office space in in san
francisco it's fairly well attended um
and i think you know we have lots of fun
lunch conversations ranging from things
like you know
a recent one was we were sort of talking
about uh micro covid if you know the
concept of micro coveted catherine olsen
who's kind of one of the creators of
microkova.org which is basically a way
of like but you know assessing the level
of risk from a given interaction or sort
of a given activity that you're doing
during combat time so we had this sort
of like fun meta conversation where like
how risky is this conversation that
we're having right now from micro
covered perspective if we like all came
into the office and tested uh but we're
still like sort of together indoors and
there's like 15 of us what does that
mean so anyway i think it's it's a it's
a fun place to work uh we've we've
obviously had a lot of fun you know kind
of getting to build it together
yeah the the things that stand out to me
are
trust and common purpose there are
enormous force multipliers um where you
know it shows up in all in all kinds of
little things where if you have you know
you can think about it in things like
like compute allocation like you know if
people are not on the same page if one
person wants to advance you know one
research agenda the other one is to
advance their other research agenda then
people fight over and there's a lot of
zero sum or negative some interactions
but if everyone has the attitude of like
we're we're we're trying to do this
thing everything we're trying to do is
in line with with you know with this
this this this common purpose and we all
trust each other to do what's right to
advance this common purpose um then yeah
it it just it really becomes a force
multiplier on you know like getting
things done while keeping the
environment like comfortable and while
everyone continues to continue to get
along with each other um i think it's i
think it's an enormous uh i think it's
an enormous superpower um that yeah that
i haven't seen before
so uh you you mentioned that you're
hiring a lot of technical people from a
wide variety of uh technical backgrounds
could you tell me a little bit more
about your your choice to do that rather
than simply hiring people who are
traditionally experienced in ml and ai
yeah that's a great question so i should
also say you know we have people from
from kind of both camps that you talked
about but
why did we choose to
um kind of bring people in from sort of
outside the field i think there's a few
reasons for this i think one is you know
again ml and ai is still a fairly a
fairly new field right not not not super
new but still pretty new and so what
that means is there's kind of a lot of
opportunity for people who have not
necessarily worked in this field before
to kind of get into it and i think we've
had sort of a lot of of uh of success or
kind of luck with taking people who are
are really talented in kind of a related
field and helping to take their skills
and translate them to the ones in in
sort of ml and ai safety and
i think the second reason is
so one is just you know expanding the
talent pool i think the other is is it
really does broaden the range of
perspectives uh and and the types of
people who are working
on on these issues which we think are
very important and again we've talked
about this you know previously but
having a wider range of of views and
kind of perspectives and approaches
tends to lead to a more robust approach
to doing to doing both basic research
and safety research
yeah nothing nothing nothing to add to
that um i mean i think
yeah
it's it's it's it's really i'm i'm just
i'm surprised at how often
someone who has experienced in a
different field can can come in and it's
not like they're like it's not like
they're directly applying things that
come but they they think about things in
a different way um and yeah i mean this
is you know of course it's true about
all kinds of things you know this is
this true about you know like yeah this
is this is true about diversity in the
more in the more traditional senses as
well but you want as many different
kinds of people as you can as you can
get
so that's where we're wrapping up here
uh i'm curious just to get some more
perspective on you guys about
you know given
these large-scale models the
importance of safety and alignment and
the
problems which exist today but also the
promises
of uh the impact they could have for the
benefit of of people what what is what's
a future that that each of you is is
excited about or what's the future that
you're hopeful for
um given your work at anthropic and um
the future impacts of ai
yeah i'll maybe i'll i'll start uh so i
think
you know one one thing i do believe is i
actually i am really hopeful about the
future i know that there's a lot of of
challenges that we have to face to get
to a sort of
a potentially you know really positive
place but i think um i think the field
will rise to the occasion or that's kind
of my hope and
i think some things i'm sort of hoping
for in the next few years is that a lot
of different groups will be developing
more practical tools uh techniques for
advancing safety research and i sort of
um
i sort of think you know
these are are likely to hopefully become
more more widely available if we can
sort of set the right norms in in the
community and i think the more people
working on safety related topics like
that can that can sort of positively
feed on itself right and i think i'm i'm
most broadly hoping for a world where we
can feel confident that when we're we're
using ai for more advanced purposes like
you know accelerating scientific
research that that it's behaving in ways
where we can be
very confident and and sure that we
understand that it's it's not going to
lead to
negative unintended consequences and the
reason for that is because we've really
taken the time to chart them out and and
understand what what all of those
potential you know um um problems could
could be and so i think that's obviously
a very ambitious goal but i think if we
can make all of that happen you know
there's a lot of potential benefits of
of more advanced ai systems that i think
could be
transformative for for the world right
from almost anything you can name right
renewable energy health disease
detection
economic growth and and sort of lots of
other just day-to-day enhancements to
kind of how we we kind of work and and
communicate and live together
no one really knows what's gonna happen
in the future it's extremely it's
extremely hard to predict and so i i
often find any any question about the
future it's it's it's more about
the the attitude or posture that that
you want to take than than it is about
about concrete predictions because i i i
feel like particularly after you go a
few years out it's just it's just very
hard to it's very hard to know what's
going to happen and so
yeah it's kind of it's it's mostly it's
mostly just speculation and so in terms
of attitude i think well first of all i
think the two attitudes that i find
least useful are like blind pessimism
and blind optimism um uh because uh
they're actually sort of you know like
doom doom doom saying and like pollyanna
ism um and you know it's possible it
weirdly is possible to have both at once
um uh but i think it's just it's just
not very useful because it's like you
know like we're all
we're all we're all doomed it's it's
intended to create fear or it's intended
to create uh to create complacency um i
i i find that an attitude that's that's
more useful is to just say well we don't
know what's going to happen but like
let's as as an individual or as an
organization like let's pick a place
where there's a problem we think we can
help with and let's try and make things
go a little better than they would have
otherwise um
maybe we'll have a small impact maybe
we'll have a big impact um but let's you
know instead of instead of trying to
understand what's gonna happen with the
whole system let's let's try and
intervene
in a way that helps with with with with
something that we feel well that we felt
feel well equipped to help with and of
course the whole outcome is you know
it's going to be beyond the scope of one
person one organization
even you know even even one country um
uh but
yeah i mean i think we find that to be
to be a more um
to to be a more effective way of
thinking about things and and for us
you know for us that's can we
help to address some of these uh safety
problems that we have with ai systems in
a way that is robust and enduring and
that points towards the future um uh you
know yeah if we can if we can increase
the probability of things going well by
only some some very some very small
amount um you know that that may that
may well be the that may well be the
most the most that we can do um you know
i think from from our perspective it
would be
you know the the things
that that i would really like to see are
i would i would like it if ai could
could do could you know advance science
technology and health
um in a way that's that's equitable for
everyone and uh that it could help
everyone to make better decisions and
improve human society and right now i
frankly don't really trust the ai
systems we build today to do any of
those things um uh
you know even even if it were
technically capable of of like the task
which it's not um i wouldn't trust to do
those things in a way that makes society
better rather than worse and so i'd like
us i'd like us to do our part to to make
it more likely that we could we could
trust trust ai systems in that in that
way uh and if we can make a small
contribution to that while while being
good citizens in the broader ecosystem
um you know yeah that's that's maybe the
best we can hope for
all right and so if people want to
check out uh
more of your work or to follow you on
social media uh where the best places to
do that
yeah uh on anthropic.com is going to be
the best place to see most of the recent
stuff we've we've worked on uh i don't
know if we have everything posted but
but yeah probably about because we have
several papers out so we're now we're
now about to post post uh post links to
them on the website
in an easy to find place uh and then we
also have a twitter handle it's just i
think it's
um on on twitter and uh
yeah and we generally you know also
tweet about our recent uh releases
we are we are relatively low key we
really want to be we really want to be
focused on the research and not not get
uh not get not get distracted um so yeah
i mean the stuff we do the stuff we do
is out there but we're we're very
focused on like the research itself and
you know getting it out and letting you
speak for itself
okay so where's the best place on on
twitter to follow anthropic it's uh uh
our twitter handle is at anthropic ai
all right i'll include a link to that in
the description of wherever you're
listening uh thanks a ton for coming on
dario and daniela it's really been
awesome and a lot of fun
um i'll include links to anthropic in
the description um it's a pleasure
having you and yeah thanks so much yeah
thanks so much for having us lucas this
was really fun
[Music]